Hello,
all you vagrants and vagaries coffee on
a Tuesday and Vlog 57.
You know,
we have to put this Tuesday thing to bed
because you guys always comment,
but you don't release on a Tuesday.
What's the deal with that?
The truth is I don't film on a Tuesday.
I don't write on a Tuesday.
Sometimes I edit on Tuesday and I most
usually don't release on a Tuesday
either.
It's just sort of become this running
joke.
I mean I sometimes think,
you know,
it's Tuesday somewhere,
but then I realized that doesn't make
any sense and then I think I just liked
the way it sounds.
Okay.
Rem Koolhaas in his famous delirious New
York writes,
the metropolis strives to reach a
mythical point where the world is
completely fabricated by man so that it
absolutely coincides with his desires.
You're right,
it's true here.
All geometries are achingly formal,
even the parks and public gardens fits
snugly into the parallelograms that the
streets and avenues draw.
Anything you want.
You can have.
The metropolis is made for consumption,
leisure,
ease of travel.
It compliments and encourages that
profound pulp fiction novel truth,
which is that after 1920,
the whole world became about Saturday
night getting set
in this round.
Each player has only one minute to
retrieve a woman's phone number.
Let's see how our players perform at
speed.
What of
the inevitability is about this city and
all cities,
I suspect is that as you consume it,
it consumes you and it fills you up with
its own self.
To the exclusion of all else,
man hadn't is the perfect metaphor for
itself because it's literally an island
and if it all of a sudden broke off and
float it out into the Atlantic,
it's unclear how many of us would really
mine.
Of course we'd have to take Brooklyn in.
Tow.
Cities are designed in a very insular
way to obscure the world outside their
walls from the ground.
You can only see a few blocks in every
direction and the city just recedes into
more city.
Its residence in this way worship the
present moment in salvos of anxiety and
pleasure,
and in that worship and within these
geometric towers,
there is no anchor to the outside world.
No frame of reference in time spins out
of control like how in the lack of
properly defined seasons,
Los Angeles skips from year to year
without remark and in the absence of
structure,
a relativism takes hold.
A feeling of an Omi sits heavily on the
salt and Omi,
the lack of social or ethical standards
in an individual or group.
As God dies and the great cities are
born and Omi is the keynote of the world
and we wait for the harvest of a
godless,
relativistic morality.
Last Friday was the full moon.
I came out of the subway and was
transfixed as transfixed as if I had
seen an intruder in my home.
It hung there brightly indifferently
shining and observing the comings and
goings of all the harried city dwellers
as the culture around them decayed and
advanced at just the same right.
I was reminded of the night a stall,
foes brief sojourn to the moon in our
stoves.
Famous Orlando Furioso were searching
for a cure to Orlando's madness.
The night comes upon that valley where
all last things on earth are found deep
in a veil conducted by his guide where
Rosa Mountain steep on either side.
He came and saw a wonder to relate
whatever was wasted in our earthly state
here,
safely treasured each neglected,
good time,
squandered or occasion it'll bestowed,
not only here our wealth inceptors found
that everchanging shift the unsteady
round,
but those possessions while on Earth we
live which fortunes hand can neither
take nor give much.
Fame is there which here the creeping
hours consume till time at length.
The whole devours their vows and their
unnumbered prayers remain,
which often God the center makes in
vain.
The frequent tiers that lover's eyes
suffuse the size they breed.
The days that gamesters lose the leisure
given which fools so often neglect the
week designs that never take effect.
Whatever designs the mortal breasts,
a sale in countless numbers filled the
uncovered vale for whatever is lost by
humankind.
Ascending here,
you treasured safe may find.
And then I wondered if a [inaudible] saw
the long lost tenants of common law or
under some garland chance to find the
sea cast fragments of unquiet mind
discarded like flattery's proffer toward
that bone white kingdom without a lord
as a fool to a stranger's care consigns
his own children and foremost rhymes
would the night please with Orlando's
vial on his chariot span the starlit
aisle,
and bring to those who cast off and
forgot the essence of this urban
thought.